Nhưng mà hảo lũi, không phải không phải nghiên triếng khảo sinh khó,
và nguyên phòng ai biết chuyện gì tế ra.
Giãi nhà liên kể chính đường lấy lợi phường bắt ra đồ sập khi công chính đang được
phá dớt để trận bị xây mới sáng chỉ thả bẩy.
Thì phát hiện công chính có giấu hiệu nghiệm, người dân hô hoán, những người bên trong kịp
trại giá ngoài trước khi nhà đồ.
Ngãi ngắm chỉ trong vào vô dài, thì mất hồi nở đó thọc,
từ cả bũ nhà, tu gà không yên thời gian chỉ có quan đó trả ngoại như là
tчес hệ tím sinh là họn con ai ở bên trong người hại không thôi,
ch 작은 buộc nụ mì ở bên ngoài la, có người con chạy tụi bㅋㅋㅋㅋu ng훈 nhà liên kể
xây này nó tốc tấp vô xói sàng tại mất sường bộv ý nhà cũng mất
sức bị mảy mất sẻ phủ trong nhà ở không một biết chảy.
Bảo ra yên k komun, nhập tâm, thật sẽ không có.
Theo chính quyền địa phương, vụ sập không kây thẻ thành bé nghỉ.
Giãi nhà cũng mùi trụ, hiện chân đã được phong bỏ để kìm chả hịp chẳng,
và dã dã xuất ăn toàn cách nhà liên kế.